[Music]
before assassin's creed tries to shake
off the stink of all the video game
movies that came before and I'm going to
kick that son of a [ __ ] Bisons ass so
hard
two films would challenge the rule that
game adaptations suck and more or less
confirm it I forgot we're fighting for
the fate of the world
Mortal Kombat and Mortal Kombat
annihilation
you remember Mortal Kombat 4 it's
pixelated ultraviolence now get ready
for two pg-13 movies that could really
use a blood code as they never deliver
on the franchise's gory gimmick but boy
do they manage to cram in everything
else
it's my bonus
get over here they even put in the
underground hamster ball Network wait
that's not from the game then what the
hell was that then enter the ultimate
high-stakes Fight Club where the fate of
the world is decided by who can beat the
most ass but these no-holds-barred bras
have only one rule there are actually a
fair amount of rules the reason quite
clear
Quenton around the earth sang song f to
win ten straight victories in mortal
kombat their sacred rules have been
broken there is one last rule she has to
accept the challenge or there can be no
final combat the rules say the earth is
safe for another generation
obviously Connors cheated and broken the
roll yeah follow the rules you guys and
also if I put a quarter up on the
machine it means I got next K read a
sprawling cast made up of fighters who
can't act Khan wants you to go after her
don't actors who can't fight and people
who can't really do either
whether you're alive too bad you will
die as you meet the heroes then meet
them all again when they're recast in
the sequel Raiden it's a new look
there's Liu Kang the boring monk who's
luscious mullet is the most interesting
part of his character Johnny Cage the
only one with any charisma oh man
Sonya Blade who's here to snap necks and
be objectified and she's all out of next
to snap nice tres katana a ten thousand
year old master of the seductive look
include that has to be Princess Kitana
a woman looks at you like that it
usually means something
rated god of exposition you have been
chosen to defend the realm of Earth in a
tournament called Mortal Kombat all the
lazy color swapped ninjas all the lazy
color swapped robots and some animators
bad CGI demon fetish
you know these actually look pretty good
for a Sega Genesis game but who cares
about water character this movie is all
about the action and these movies have
some of that feast your eyes on over a
dozen chopped alee edited generic
martial arts battles against wave after
wave of faceless karate goons and a
claymation finale that will have you
saying this is hilarious I can't believe
someone actually made this watched it
and then still released it so if you
love the Mortal Kombat games for their
stories and don't like actually playing
them watch actors put on Halloween
costumes of your favorite characters
then act out the windscreens of the
first two games but there's still one
thing in these movies that the games
could never match the most epic theme
song ever
[Music]
and they are not going to let you forget
it
[Music]
gone astray loss whoa
who wants to fight released play some
laser tag or something yo I'm psyched
starring over Annika Vaughn so hot want
to touch the hiney
mullet comeback the Skylander ol [ __ ]
punch and Johnny Frigidaire pumps are
deadly knees weak arms is heavy only
only only when I oh I doctor Quattro
puss down back low kick back back low
punch hold down high punch and chang-su
standing up
[Music]
exit the dragon
you know she's 10,000 years old right
wait a poor reverse Twilight I still tap
that though be sure to subscribe for
more honest trailers hey screen junkies
can't get enough of my buttery voice
then click the box on the right to see
my epic voice review of rogue one a star
war story and while you're there check
out tons of other epic voice reviews
trailer reactions and original content
featuring me the epic voice guy what are
you waiting for do it now I'm one with a
force and the force is with me what we
have some kind of collateral Beauty do
you even read my Christmas list
cinnamon toast crunch for brunch why you
stuck-up half-witted scruffy-looking
nerf-herder
what's the boat's name in Titanic